énorme webcam qui nous a sorti Razer
c'est le Kyo pro ultra c'est une webcam
qui est juste énorme vous pouvez avoir
de la 4K 24 images par seconde sans
aucune compression le truc est dingue
c'est un très gros capteur qui vous
permet de restituer une très très belle
luminosité alors en plus vous avez un
software à l'intérieur qui est vachement
bien pensé vous allez pouvoir avoir ici
un zoom lire zoomer dans l'image vous
déplacez plus haut plus bas ça va
dépendre de ce que vous voulez ça c'est
vachement pratique avoir également un
focus automatique ou un focus manuel
soit de la reconnaissance de visage
grâce à de l'intelligence artificielle
ou alors également un mode standard si
vous voulez ensuite montrer les objets
vous mettez votre main devant vous
l'enlevez ça va venir reconnaître votre
visage c'est pratique pareil également
au niveau de la lumière il y a
différentes options et après on peut
aller plus loin également avec une
exposition automatique ou manuelle on
peut venir changer ses ISO son shutter
speed également et pour du lights stream
surtout vos réseaux sociaux et bien vous
avez une webcam signée Razer avec un
énorme capteur on ouvre ici à f1.7 c'est
la Clio pro ultra elle me séduit je
trouve jolie et en plus vous avez un
côté sécurité privacy où on vient
tourner on ferme la webcam on peut venir
la rouvrir ça c'est un clean c'est sympa
bref innovation ciné Razer je sais pas
ce que vous en pensez dites le moi dans
les commentaires personnellement j'aime
beaucoup